based on your submissions our parent
company nexstar has chosen its top four
choices of remarkable women of nevada
and today we introduce you to maggie
carlton who's the longest-serving female
legislator in our state
i grew up in the show me state but i'm a
nevadan by choice and that's where my
heart lies
maggie carlton moved to the east part of
las vegas in 1990 securing a job as a
coffee waitress in treasure island
where she took a big interest in the
culinary union and politics
a lot of it had to do with being a
working mom
who wanted to represent folks from the
perspective of a working mom we walked
the frontier picket line
on fridays and i took my daughters down
there to walk the picket line maggie was
chosen as an active member of the
culinary
union to introduce then president bill
clinton the president
of the united states and it wasn't long
before this waitress with a high school
diploma
became the first labor activist to be
elected to the nevada state
senate a couple of the more seasoned
legislators back then tell the story
that
they they had no idea where this this
young waitress came from and
you know they thought i was going to
show up in a motorcycle jacket in
stiletto heels or something i mean they
were
they were just joking but you know i i
was an unknown i came out of
out of nowhere this unknown at the time
would later become the ultimate
stereotype buster representing the
little guy across our state on very
important matters
it was very nerve-wracking because i had
never done
anything like that before the major
challenges for her came with balancing
family life
if you stop and think about it i've done
this for 22 years and they're 34 and 35
years old so
it's been most of their lives they've
had a mom that's in the legislature so
that's that's been one of the biggest
challenges is is balancing that and
always making sure that i was
there for them you know as much as i
could be here's a snippet from inside
edition when maggie a senator at the
time
and still a cafe waitress was profiled
on her political career
do you think you'd vote for her in 2011
maggie was elected to the nevada
assembly
and became the longest serving woman
legislature in nevada's history
now being able to help the next
generation that's coming up
she has been chair of the ways and means
committee since 2013.
one of her biggest accomplishments took
10 years of her life to complete
tackling surprise hospital billing if
you're out on the soccer field and your
your daughter falls and and breaks the
elbow or whatever
you don't think about what hospitals and
network you just up you take them to the
closest hospital you walk in the
emergency room door
and you get them treatment well a lot of
times what would happen after that is
the surprise bill would come later and
now hospitals and insurance companies
negotiate on your behalf
while these big issues are certainly
important maggie finds the littler ones
most satisfying when somebody calls you
and there's
there's a street light out on their
street or they're having problems with
the sidewalk or their child needed a
zone variance
or there was an issue with the neighbor
the fact that you could reach out and
help people
do things for their everyday life it
was very it's very very gratifying as
for being nominated as a remarkable
woman of nevada i was just so surprised
and emotional about the letter submitted
on her behalf
written by her husband it was very
important
you know because you know sometimes
after 40 years of marriage you don't
appreciate each other as much or share
as much
you just kind of you know we're there
for each other but
the fact that he took the time to do
that means a lot
maggie will continue her work as
executive director with non-profit you
land the united labor agency of nevada
in 2022 after 24 years of public service
she says she'll be turned out and she
says it'll be tough to get politics out
of her blood
but she adds one good thing about term
limits is that you're always getting new
people and she believes that's a good
thing for the state of nevada
as it's constantly changing